Dan!
Thanks for coming!
>> Yeah, I heard you wanted to talk
about Sunshine, great app isn't it?
>> Yeah, it's a great learning exercise,
and with a little more polish
it could be a great prototype.
>> Prototype?
I thought we were done with Sunshine.
Wasn't that what the great
party was all about?
>> Well, you're half right.
It was a great party.
Look, Sunshine does function,
but we've got a long way to go
before it's production ready.
Remember, it's that last 10% of
polishing those unique features that
make all the difference to real users.
Get it ready for real users, and then
you'll be ready for your own lab coat.
Maybe.
>> Well, sure, I had a couple things
in mind that we didn't get to.
>> Great.
I thought you'd have some ideas.
And I've brought in some extra help for
you to get it done.
You need to go talk to the fix-it team.
>> So I guess I should be leaving now?
Here's to more Sunshine.
[MUSIC]
So, I've got this app, and
it's not production quality,
and students are watching,
and I need your help.
>> Sure, we can take a look.
[SOUND] Yeah.
>> Mm.
>> Oh my.
Mm, well,
this is certainly functional and
we can work with you to help
you make it production ready.
>> Awesome,
what do we need to do to get started?
>> I think it would be good to hear from
you on exactly where Sunshine is now.
>> No time like the present.
Let's go.